(Music)
Woman passenger:
Just how many of these things
have you dealt with?
Woman driver:
More than most people feel
comfortable knowing about.
(Music)
Woman passenger:
And how many
times have you failed?
More times than most people
would feel comfortable knowing
about.
(Music)
Woman:
What if it does these
things for a reason?
(Music)
Maybe all this always happened.
Man:
Maybe you were always meant
to come back with me.
(Music)
I gotta figure this out.
I may have something.
Great, buckle up.
(Music)
You're a superhero, Grandpa!
Cool.
(Music)
Man:
That's not a coincidence.
(Music)
You gotta do something big.
I'll see you on the other side.
(Music)
It's a pretty good story, you be
nice...
...I'll tell it to you sometime.
(Music)